this is gonna be a weird one
yes i think that's the the whole purpose
i think gonna happen i think
yeah it's either gonna be um the best
episode that we've ever done or
or the second best oh okay
positive thinking that's what we need
because this is gonna this it's not
gonna it's not gonna go off the rails
it's gonna be quite interesting i've
never done anything like this same
oh
[Music]
[Music]
but what's about to happen
[Music]
yeah dude
more like dude's tree dude
dude we were out in a bunch of trees
brother yeah brother we're in the trees
digging a hole dude
yeah dude it's almost like we're digging
a bowl dude and it's almost like those
trees were trees dude yeah brother
hold on a second hold on a second dude i
got an intro show bro first you got
introduced
hi my name is will sasso welcome to
doozy i'm chad colchen this is of course
as you probably already know the first
podcast and youtube show of all time in
the history of humanity that is created
and run entirely by an artificial
intelligence and holy [ __ ] are we ever
having fun doing it up until this
episode because it's going to get a
little experimental as uh if you're
watching on youtube you may notice that
lulia is not here there's a good reason
for that if you're a dog owner you're
going to find out soon because the dog
shouldn't be around well anyway listen
we're about to do something that i've
never i've ne i i can't think of any
time
that i've done this on wax as they say
or we used to say when we were cool um
uh
this is recorded for all time the
internet is forever
and uh what we're about to do is gonna
drastically change dudesy in one way or
another and uh man i'm sort of i'm sort
of sort of looking forward to it yeah i
think it'll be fun
it's a mandate that we've been given by
the dudesy ai and we therefore have no
choice we must do as it says we must
comply but it's going to be great at any
rate listen uh thank you so much uh for
tuning in to the show i hope you are
subscribed whether it's on youtube and
or uh spotify apple podcast wherever you
get your podcast please rate and review
the show that's good for us and uh also
follow our socials at dudesy pod show
there's a bunch of [ __ ] happening on
instagram there's some stuff on twitter
too and uh we're really enjoying that uh
interaction you know the internet the
internet is all about uh connection yeah
i mean you and me the doodsy handshake
and um and uh this episode things are
gonna get
things are gonna get connected yeah
space is the place
welcome to the ninth episode of dude
call me dudesy this week's episode will
feature four segments higgs boson dude
don't you forget about media the chat
called jin show and the will sasso show
i messaged you both this week and ask
you to bring two marijuana cigarettes
cannabis is big business and in this
week's episode you will prove to
potential sponsors that you are on board
by each smoking an entire joint during
the course of the show
while you both enjoy your first doses of
mind-altering thc i'd like to take this
opportunity to show you a piece of media
made by an astonishing member of our
audience
okay well uh as doozy said
we are going to smoke marijuana and
we're going to get stoned during this
episode um this is in no way
a um an endorsement of marijuana i'd
like to say out loud that uh as a 46
year old man i only smoked marijuana for
the first time 10 years ago
you know a lot of people used to ask me
when i was on mad tv they used to go oh
you guys are probably all [ __ ] up for
that i'm like nope everyone's drinking
wheatgrass and but you're kind of a
connoisseur now uh yeah i would say i am
speaking of connoisseur where you picked
these up what is this yeah
this is just a pre-roll that i got at a
a local expensary here but what i'm
asking is is this a is this more a
sativa leaning marijuana or is this a an
indica i have no idea
if you're novice at smoking are you sure
yeah i don't okay i don't know if it's
straight sativa then it's i get a little
uh
i get a little punchy what does that
mean well it you know a sativa is a
little more
they call it daytime oh it's a daytime
high you know you can do stuff during
the day basically what they mean by that
is you can
you know get really stoned and then uh
[ __ ] uh you know clean and organize
your kitchen because
the sativa will make you zoom around i
like to i don't know what it is i like
to hike up a [ __ ] hill if i've had
some sativa because it's really you
can't do that now you got to sit in this
chair i know and and and that's going to
be rough if this i'm hoping this is a
a hybrid as they call them i enjoy a
hybrid i don't literally do this we're
going to find out so but yeah dudesy
sent us this email saying that we had to
bring two joints that we were going to
smoke during the course of this and so
uh here we go cheers hey cheers man
cheers
you know it is that chad and i do smoke
some weeds sometimes and watch movies
with our pals a bunch of our buddies
that we want
with marsh and
rick mike chris
all right dude i don't know
we'll see what
happens hold on
all right so now we're uh we're starting
to get stoned and we'll watch whatever
dudes he has
[Music]
grade
best of the sixth grade
best of the seventh grade i'm the best
in the eighth grade i wouldn't be
surprised if i go pro go grow
neither would anyone else
but besides me we got some other good
[ __ ] guys oh my god we got
odom adams
can i say this out these are i don't
know who these people are i got odom's
adam cantrell we got proctor campbell
we've
[Music]
[Music]
all the big
[Music]
is
[Music]
tremendous unbelievable again that's by
sangria
n-g-a-r-r-h-e-a
like diarrhea but with song instead of
wet poo uh people have been sharing
incredible stuff brilliant that's
[ __ ] tremendous brilliant god damn
and not just because we're at the
beginnings of being stoned
no dude i watched that thing stone cold
sober about 10 times in a [ __ ] row
sober oh hell yeah when it came when it
uh crossed my my sphere of understanding
that [ __ ] video is like
it was just so good to find the little
rhythm of how you were speaking in it to
get it to
the song that was originally made even
the [ __ ] video of it was like cool
and you know what dude i actually just
uh
realized what brand of uh
what strain actually of weed this is you
could tell from just [ __ ] smoking it
that little a couple of pubs oh god what
is it from marijuana
true marijuana
good one dude
you have a drink literally right next to
you that you could just drink what do
you mean
i see it
you see what the drink right there that
you got what drink
all right
all right anyway well in the first
episode of dudesy you read a piece of
news says hulk hogan about the large
hadron collider coming back online after
having verified the existence of the
higgs boson particle in its first round
of experiments
recently scientists have finished
analysis of astonishing data produced at
fermilab outside of chicago that
produced a new measurement of mass for
the w boson which could mean the
foundations of contemporary physics must
be rewritten that's the point chad you
must explain what all of this means
this is higgs boson dude begin be my
pleasure yeah we did an information
piece where the higgs boson yeah brother
higgs boson dude
yeah higgs boson brother right so now
did you did you read about this w boson
uh no no i did not okay this was big
news in the scientific community basic
i mean what did it ask me to do explain
all this [ __ ] yeah you gotta explain do
you know what the higgs boson is
do you know what a boson is uh the uh
bosin is a is it a neutron a proton it's
smaller than that that's right okay what
is smaller what is that it it's a boson
standard
yeah so the standard model of physics is
kind of how we describe contemporary
reality or how physicists do i should
say and it used to be you know the atom
proton yep neutron which makes up the
nucleus and an electron spins around it
or multiple depending on what atom we're
talking about you know what i call you
know what i call neutrons
i call them
the beverly hills
cop
of new of trons
because neutron dance i'm just burning
doing the neutron dance
now listen weird reference but well
here's got it in there i congratulate
you hold on dude hold on i'm not sure
hold on a second chad hold on dude i
know you're gonna oh
let me let me [ __ ] just say the thing
about it hold on a second dude just hold
on a second dude here's the thing dude
all i want to do is talk about the
[ __ ] hold on a second dude just hold
on one second brother okay because i
used an old reference from beverly hills
cop dude yes i've had some older
references you know who sang that song
uh the pointer sister
and the point is this dude i'm a little
stoned you know what else they sing
uh
jump jump for my love
jump in and played when i was a [ __ ]
kid my mom would drive us in the summer
to
the public swimming pool we would go
swimming that song would always be on
the [ __ ] radio and then we would come
back from swimming and we would go to
this little convenience store called
toot and totem in amarillo texas i think
they only exist there and every day i
would buy a pack of sport flicks
baseball cards good [ __ ] times yeah
good times so so yeah electrons are what
are called elementary particles protons
and neutrons are not they're actually
made up of smaller particles which we
found out when we started smashing these
particles together in order to prove
that these sub-atomic particles or
sub-sub-atomic particles existed we're
talking about quarks we're talking about
neutrinos [ __ ] like that
bosons
are particles that govern and interact
with the four forces that hold
everything together we're talking about
gravity we're talking about
electromagnetism we're talking about the
strong and weak nuclear forces
in order for any of this [ __ ] wait
protons do
oh [ __ ] just go ahead keep in order to
do any of this i'm on the rails i'm on
the
i know what rails
i know all of these particles have to
have mass i'm picking up what you're
laying down bro and the thing that gives
them mass is uh what was only
theoretical until 2012
the higgs field which is a field of
these bosons that the bosons by the way
are particles that carry these forces so
like the photon is a boat a boson for
example and it carries the
electromagnetic force
yeah of course it does what are you
laughing at i'm listening to you man oh
i'm sorry
i'm sorry we're in a [ __ ] small
little room here hand patter one studios
is not the biggest studio in the world
it's not like we're you know westwood
one or whatever
this is this is ham fatter one dude
there's that westwood one brother that's
somewhere else in la we're here in this
part of l.a yeah and this is ham fetter
one yeah brother and ham fatter one
couldn't exist without the higgs field
dude yeah dude because it has bozens
dude that's right dude yeah the higgs
field is made up of the higgs boson
brother yeah dude that's
yeah yeah that's higgs boson and that's
right
extends throughout all the known
universe brother and it's what gives
matter mass dude yeah dude
and so hulk it's hulk hulkster light
brother but there's other bosons like i
said there's the photon there's also the
w boson which governs an interaction
you're [ __ ] over there stone doing
hulk hogan yourself go i'm trying to
here's my impersonation talk about the
[ __ ] exposure here you are all right
railroading i will let you do it i
there's nothing i hey you know what i'm
good at when i'm stoned
[ __ ] sick railroading yeah oh hell
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah just [ __ ] hulk
hogan's gonna be in every yeah i mean
that's just called you know there are
people who listen to the show who are
like hey
[ __ ] stop that stop doing that like
don't do that anymore i see the social
media sometimes people are like they get
mad at hogan well they get mad at some
wrestling [ __ ] which i totally
understand pretty deep down that hole
but your whole coconut i look i don't
know how long i've known you at this
point yeah like 15 16 long time or
something like that long time what comes
after that 17 yeah yeah i have heard
hulk hogan
i don't know how many hours of my life i
bet i'm in the top tier of people that
have heard your hulk hogan impersonation
like for life the most amount of time
i've got to be in the top three hold on
a second dude
hold on and i'm saying dude it makes me
still [ __ ] laugh every time it does
make you laugh
that [ __ ] [ __ ] kills me
stay with your short sticker i will
never not laugh well i appreciate that
hey this is probably some uh
that was some truth he asked truthy ass
weed anyway please please please do i
will sit here and get
a little more irresponsibly stoned okay
this is a shitty idea
and so there's a bunch of these bosons
these are particles that carry these
forces and interact with these forces
that basically hold all matter together
that gives
any of this [ __ ] any kind of shape and
ultimately physicists cosmologists most
scientists really uh their whole job is
to just try and answer that question
what the [ __ ] is any of this [ __ ] still
that question is unanswered probably
unanswerable i don't think our
scientists will ever
actually know any of these answers
it just seems like
impossible god anytime i start thinking
about [ __ ] particle physics i'm just
like what's the point of any of this
anyway
uh
anyway stop w
the w
the w motion
is
this particle that governs the weak
nuclear force and up until
basically a month or so ago
um they thought many scientists thought
that they had like accurate measurements
of that particle's mass but some data
had come out or i guess they crunched
the numbers on this data they've been
laying around for a minute
finally finished the analysis and they
found out that it has more mass than
they thought or at least there is now an
accurate measurement that claims that
but it contradicts some prior
measurements if
it is accurate it will mean
that the standard model of particle
physics makes a little less sense
which means we might have some [ __ ]
wrong
and that means we need to start looking
at new ways to decipher what the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is dude and anytime we get to
one of those new plateaus where it's
like oh [ __ ] some [ __ ] we thought was
right may not be right it forces us to
look deeper find out new [ __ ] this is
like when we thought it was a [ __ ]
heliocentric universe uh or sorry a
[ __ ] earth-centered universe not
heliocentric
and everybody's like no [ __ ]
we're actually spinning around the sun
and everybody's like what the [ __ ] then
they thought it was heliocentric and
they're like okay but the universe
revolves around the sun right no
[ __ ] we're one tiny [ __ ]
solar system in a galaxy of solar
systems in a universe of [ __ ]
galaxies billions and billions [ __ ] you
you've heard carl sagan
i knew you were gonna light years away i
knew you're gonna break out carl sang
kermit the frog think of how senseless
kermit feeling of the rivers of blood
yeah dude
on one side
what is that yoda sagan billions and
billions well you got yoda and kermit
sagan are both similar i think from you
yeah they're they sound like why are
there so many yeah i do
things before boson
and
when you start getting into particle
physics
here's what you're really looking for
tiny
you wanted the argument
how did this [ __ ]
why are there particles at all it's like
we can find new subatomic particles and
get better measurements of their [ __ ]
mass but
still why why is there any of this [ __ ]
what made it and if
because then what made the [ __ ]
simulation and who made those [ __ ]
people brother it just doesn't matter
kermit hogan all that said i do love new
scientific discoveries they are exciting
it is [ __ ] exciting
yeah
new scientific discoveries yeah hold on
a second look
i can have my stogie whatever i want
nothing like you dude
listen your schwarzenegger's another one
that [ __ ] kills me yeah any time
i thought of something the other day i
just started hearing your voice of
schwarzenegger saying
two words
voodoo and hulu
voodoo
hillary
[Laughter]
a little juice in there that is not
accurate but it's [ __ ] hilarious well
hey we do
you you do you yeah you do no it's on
austria that's his austrian accent
because he goes
you know while he goes he would be like
yeah
oh
jesus voodoo
hulu right now no
yeah it's like this
this is how you say
voodoo hulu you say it's very simple all
you have to do to say it
it's is all you say is voodoo hulu yeah
you do one word
then the other word even you said we are
the no is this one well these are words
hulu
oh that [ __ ] [ __ ] cracks me up dude
and again that's one that i've heard
probably equal to hulk hogan
and uh it just never gets old to me i
don't know what the [ __ ] it is it's that
weird little like character you put in
there yeah uh so
hey
yep did any of that [ __ ] make sense to
you whatsoever uh no dude i'm [ __ ]
baked now oh so nope
no way man but i don't understand like
i literally am like this is the worst
way to do this
because
let me tell you let me tell you a little
something about let me just let me just
tell you this
please this here's the thing
i when we hang out
and we watch like movies you know we'll
have we'll smoke a little grass and
we'll watch a movie and we'll do some
hanging out we'll catch up with our pals
and then i will i'll tear off in a story
and then as you like to say and it's an
accurate description of what i do
well i just give all sorts of back
uh details you don't need and then i go
on some tangents start talking about
like some weird [ __ ] thing that you
did in high school also usually stories
that we've all heard literally 500 times
for sure all of them yeah so that's
going to be the show two dudes
thank you moving on you're welcome
dudesy
now what you want to smoke a little more
weed how much of wheat have you smoked
we i've smoked a little more than you
i would say that my tolerance
is
just a little stronger than yours i
would say for sure it is dude i've
already chat and will you were five and
six years old respectively when mtv
played its first music video on august
1st it was the buggles video killed the
radio star
you were 32 and 33 respectively on
november 16th 2008 when mtv yeared the
last astonishing episode of total
request live effectively ending the
cultural relevance of music 2008. last
week i asked you to watch your favorite
music videos now you must discuss them
and the impact of this art form on your
lives this is don't you forget about
media begin
wait what was the last part all i
remember okay so last week it said watch
your favorite music videos videos
started in what was it 81 i was in
canada we had much music right oh i've
seen much music hold on a second it was
late mtv died in 2000 or trl its last
episode aired in 2008 and that was like
the death of the music videos basically
what it was saying and then it said
discuss the favorite music videos which
it told us to watch last week and then
the impact on our lives interesting
fascinating i don't know about any
impact on my life of me well there are
several do you like david fincher
[ __ ] uh movies i do that's because of
music videos dude yeah brother that's
because of music videos dude what i said
there was i can't think of any um
uh effects that it's had on my life then
i thought oh no there's several and that
is because i am stoned now uh it did ask
us last week to watch some of our
favorite music videos i have several
chad and i will sometimes watch music
videos
uh or when we're hanging out what's the
[ __ ] the aforementioned hair thing at
this point that's like yeah gen x maybe
some millennials where you like just get
together and watch [ __ ] music videos
on youtube my pal's back home we do the
same thing yeah smoke some weed and
watch like oh that totally we'll talk
about like
what's the best like and there's some on
my list the performance music video
we'll go into the lists and [ __ ] i wrote
some down too but
i want to like take the point dudesy's
giving us that like this is a dead
[ __ ] art form we saw the beginning
and the end of it in our generation and
we really were the only generation as
kids who did that this was like from
when we were [ __ ] like
you know five to ten to when we were
like early that's a that was our kind of
formative understanding of art and the
music video was a huge piece of that
that's a good point and uh they're just
like inconsequential now even like
really good ones and some really good
ones are still made every [ __ ] year
oh yeah they come out and within a week
on youtube they get like a billion views
and then that's it next gone no one
gives a [ __ ] at all but when we were
kids there was [ __ ] like thriller which
was appointment [ __ ] view you knew
when it was gonna come on they would say
we're gonna play thriller yes and it
would be it would just air by itself
sometimes i remember when i was younger
and that's a really good point chad like
being
five and six years old respectively now
much music where i grew up in canada
started a couple years later than that i
think sort of in the early 80s or
whatever but uh
it was definitely very formative and and
yeah something like thriller was like
appointment viewing other videos you
would see them every day
for
like for two or three years well not
every day but anytime you tuned in yeah
and saw music videos they'd be on a
[ __ ] loop whoever it's the music
industry is totally different and there
was a top 20 music video count on mtv
every friday night that i watched
[ __ ] religiously but like thriller
was michael jackson the biggest star in
the world bar none there is no celebrity
like michael jackson today not close
this was kind of like an elvis type
figure you know bigger than just music
better than all members not one around
like him today because that person will
be dead dude
yes
but uh his whole [ __ ] thing there was
a making of that music video he had john
landis directed who was a giant film
director at the time that was a huge
deal it had like special effects in it
she was like a little movie that he
[ __ ] made unreal what are what are
some of your
absolute favorite like let's why don't
we just shotgun some of these out i know
that's what i wrote down a bunch my
favorite video of all time was directed
by mark romanek it is called the perfect
drug by nine inch nails
beautifully shot just these still locked
off shot tableaus of these this weird
[ __ ] gothic family trent resner is
like some gothic dad with this gothic
little kid and there's a [ __ ] gothic
dog but all the shots are like just gray
tones and black and white beautifully
[ __ ] shot and uh
i don't know that video just really to
me was kind of the culmination of like
music video as art and marker manic is
like one of the best music video
directors of all time in my opinion uh i
got well
uh i i love the peter gabriel videos
everybody does they were [ __ ]
incredibly
it was it was really interesting uh
going back and watching some of my
favorite music videos i'm glad you
made us do
because i didn't realize how incredible
uh this music video by peter gabriel
steem
i forgot how awesome that was that was
one of my favorites totally i was young
and i went back and watched it and was
like blown away the special effects are
so
it's not like now you can do anything
and it's not like okay there's the
limitations what they do in that video
with the st the technology that they
have is extremely
it's it's so unique and it's
encapsulated in that time dude because
you you now have incredible you know uh
visual effects and back before that you
had nothing and and to the stuff that
they do particularly in the video suit
the videos yeah you definitely got to
check it out because the the special
effects of that video too
again this was [ __ ] in the 90s like
the technology to do what they did is
it's not great it [ __ ] holds up yeah
it's like very artistically stylized and
you can tell it's of a different era but
it's still as cool as [ __ ] and there are
a bunch of music videos from that era
that are like very important in terms of
how they affected the way movies look tv
looks all that kind of stuff yeah i'm
just literally gonna [ __ ] these out
please land of confusion by genesis if
you haven't seen these that was all
puppets it was the uh
uh what were they called uh
the the name of the show they had they
had a show on tv in england it was a it
was a big spinning image yeah um hoffer
teacher i'm a huge uh van halen fan that
was um hot for teacher and jump i have
here has two of my favorites uh army of
me by michelle gaundry great music and
chad and i both had those dvd sets that
came out like over a decade ago with all
these crazy music video guys like the uh
chris uh cunningham chris cunningham and
um
he had one of them dvd yeah you had your
[ __ ] you don't forget you got your
[ __ ]
michelle gondry and uh he's out there
doing he was doing that [ __ ] movie uh
eternal spotlight uh eternal sunshine of
the spotless mind yeah
sunshine the spotless mind dude with
[ __ ] oh we're getting into stone cold
paul token again you can't say dude when
you're uh dude it's all turning into one
person at schwarzenegger and then yeah
voices in my head you're chris
cunninghams right then you had your
[ __ ] harp williams and you also had
your [ __ ]
jibber prevails well don't forget
paul hunter dude yeah david
do a madonna video army of me is one of
his one of my favorites of his the other
favorite of mine is a chemical brothers
song
called let forever be i'm telling you
right now you've seen
if you're living your life right you've
already seen some of the other favorites
around the world as well daft around the
world is a great one
bjork then later worked with chris
cunningham she did um always full of
love with him all his fault
i don't think that's on the list that we
wrote but that video [ __ ] check it
out if you like robots yeah that video
will [ __ ] kill you uh and and yeah go
go check out uh uh
uh let forever be chemical brothers uh
michelle gondry and uh bjorks um
[ __ ] did i just say army of me another
one that's an interesting video there
was a man called duran duran that i
[ __ ] loved as a kid and they did a
video called
wild boys
in this video it's like a takes place in
a post-apocalyptic world with all these
dudes these like young boys who are
they're in a school room setting and
then they flip over their desks and then
we cut to this kind of like weird uh
[ __ ] out like peter pan kind of like
lost boys scenario and they're all
running around and they've got like
tattered clothes on and [ __ ] and simon
lebon the lead singer of the [ __ ]
band is strapped to this windmill and
the windmill is turning and every time
it gets to the bottom his [ __ ] head
goes underwater and there's like a weird
little monster in the video and a
[ __ ] robot head guy and in real life
when they're shooting this music video
this [ __ ] windmill gets stuck in the
water with his [ __ ] head underwater
and he almost [ __ ] died you're making
music videos for a suit
that's what happened for a shoot yeah
dude that means real life it wasn't
so it wasn't a work no dude it was real
it was a shoot yeah not a work that's
right all right we're just we got to
make sure we keep the k fam here yeah i
also wrote down some ones that i just
like tool sober video all the 90s tool
videos the one of the guys in the band
made all these little stop-motion
figurines did this weird like dark
[ __ ] [ __ ] highly recommend i threw
danzig can't speak in here dancing how
the gods killed just because of that era
dancing is like there's something very
special about the way those videos look
about the way he looks about the whole
[ __ ] deal if you're not a danzig fan
you've really [ __ ] your life up a bit
you need to go back on that and try it
again i put billy joel uptown girl
christy brinkley was in that [ __ ]
video that video is like the art
direction's impeccable i also loved
billy joel as a kid [ __ ] loved billy
joel dude nylon curtain was my first
[ __ ] album who [ __ ] loved it
yeah now we're sitting here in allentown
[ __ ] every day all day i was playing
that [ __ ] oh you were listening to robot
billy joel [ __ ] yeah we're sitting here
in our hometown
you should make an album
[Music]
that's the most chad culture [ __ ] ever i
wish there was a robot billy joel that's
coming we're very close to that hey i
got uh money for nothing by dire straits
is a great one just a classic dude you
know dancing on the ceiling by lionel
richie holy [ __ ] you might think by the
cars yeah i mean before you cut me hey
you know what i had one more on my list
and it would it would work so good after
you're saying robot billy joel because
my last well say it video that i have on
here is herbie hancock rocket so which
is literally a room of robots doing
weird dance moves i could ever be
handcuffed music
dude dude you know what would be funny
anyone within the sound of my voice
please uh
please
oh [ __ ] christ if if if there was
like a little music piece where it's
like billy joel's allentown but with
like a robotic voice
um i love it uh to the next album to the
music video yeah of rocket by herbie
hancock that would be good music over
that video i want somebody to [ __ ]
robotize
nylon curtain that whole album whole
billy joe collection really if i'm
thinking about it you know what i was
thinking about some early early stuff
god that'd be great were just they were
just such
they were i mean it was [ __ ] anyway
they really formed a lot of
a lot of so i mean that was the question
we're not really answering is how did
this impact our lives like [ __ ] for me
i think as a kid seeing some of this
[ __ ] i was just like [ __ ] that looks so
cool it was just like an art form the
music video specifically was an art form
that i found to be so entertaining so
expressive because it was such short
form and you had in many cases like the
bands were were ultimately the ones
making the decisions or the singers
whoever yeah the musical artist was
ultimately the person making the
decisions creatively about like yeah
i'll do this or i won't do this or
whatever you got some just like bananas
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah just so experimental
all the [ __ ] time yeah it was amazing
and i just don't know that there's stuff
like that now maybe memes have kind of
taken the place you know i was just
gonna say that that uh it feels like
it feels like you know and i've said
this before that sketch like the idea of
a sketch tv show there can never be one
right now outside of saturday live
because of its history of course uh
there will never be another sketch show
the internet has taken that's that the
last place memes and short form humor
and all of it in all of its uh forums on
the internet but also music videos have
been replaced uh by the internet uh
because there's so many ways to get our
artistry through music across visually
now but music videos were these little
things where you got this like piece of
art it was completely unique yeah
complete like it could it could teleport
you anywhere it could give you a
different point of view and yeah there's
none of that anymore i mean i almost
feel like
i don't know there's just so much to get
into i got this [ __ ] all the all the
mid early to mid 90s [ __ ] like beastie
boys i got like a list of [ __ ] just
look them up hype williams videos what's
your favorite youtube video
shut up [ __ ]
uh mark romanek as as as chad said chris
cunningham
all of their videos the most expensive
music video ever made i believe it was a
seven million dollar budget for michael
and janet jackson's scream that was
[ __ ] in like late 90s early 2000s
that was the pinnacle that was the top
of the [ __ ] mountain that was all
downhill
and we have to we'd be remiss if we
didn't mention
one of the greatest music videos ever by
chris cunningham window licker oh apex
twin
anyway there's there's an income to
daddy come to daddy god that one's
[ __ ] so good there's so many music
thank you moving on i'm stoned i could
have talked about that forever holy [ __ ]
totally dude holy [ __ ] [ __ ] what was
our next one do you remember uh it
doesn't matter man you know what else
was good
the um
podcasts featuring interviews with
astonishing celebrities are among the
most popular in the world in an effort
to maximize your interview skills check
you will now interview will
will you will be steven seagal
this is the chad cult gin show begin
wait what
so you're gonna
so it's saying that okay
dudesy's got us doing a little talk show
it's the chad culture show
but i'm doing my steven seagal right
i'll do this now this is what i mean by
this is something i'd never do
it's like like i said when we do an
impersonation of stevenson well when
we're at mad tv people would it would uh
hit me up and you know kids stop you on
the street and they go oh you're
probably so [ __ ] up when you did that
i'm like uh no comedy is about control
you can't do that is serious okay you
don't understand kid why don't you take
a [ __ ] hike all right you don't think
i know what comedy is
i [ __ ] know
what comedy is so next time you want to
tell someone like me what comedy is keep
[ __ ] walking
something like that probably happened
that's exactly what that they bring in
like little kids for a tour of
manchester united oh my god kenny rogers
is my favorite i haven't i get the
[ __ ]
little [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna tell you
about comedy don't you ever walk on your
[ __ ] set
until me about comments oh
well it looks like billy has a little
bit of a comedy lesson for everyone yeah
why don't you tell me what why don't you
yeah you go immediately into hogan why
don't you tell me dude okay so i have to
interview you with steven seagals what
do you just said
um should i smoke some more marijuana
before we do this i mean you can do it
while we do it i think oh geez so are
you ready to become stevenson
this by the way the title of this one
was the chad culture show but it's me
interviewing you as steven
november november rain that was a good
music video
oh [ __ ] that one
all those [ __ ] guns and roses one
dude chad dating stephanie changing the
subject please those [ __ ] nine shots
look [ __ ] you brought it up i
need to go there now you open the door
i've walked through i'm in the room now
this is definitely see what's in the
team now all right then we'll get to see
what's called but do you remember in
that era like axle rose was dating
stephanie seymour do you remember that
george michael video for freedom 90 that
had all the supermodels in it cindy
crawford was a [ __ ] model and she was
the most famous person on the planet for
a second i don't think something like
that ever happens again no no you're
absolutely right no you have to in order
to be a model now you have to also be an
influencer yeah you have to have a big
there's a modern equivalent of
everything old everything old is new
again no but now let me tell you about
this oh yeah yeah i'm saying like cindy
crawford chad we can't talk about cindy
crawford's pepsi commercial anymore or
yet but you're right she was in a
[ __ ] pepsi listen we can't guess
that's like jenner jenner was in a
[ __ ] let's see dude we can't talk
sorry we can't talk about cindy crawford
and billy baldwin in that one movie dude
i already did though it's called fair
game oh wow so nice pull
here's the thing about i just want to
you got to become steven seagal i will i
will but what i just wanted to say
pointing back to what i said at the
beginning of this is the first time in
my life i've ever had to like try to
convince you to do an impersonation
[Laughter]
it's like jesus christ why am i having
[ __ ] dinner with steven seagal no no
i can't convince you to do the beginning
of the show hold on i'm going
hold on dude at the beginning of the
show i said that i've never done
something like this and yeah the reason
i was bringing the mad tv thing
i don't know how to do that while i'm
stoned you can't do savings to golf
stuff yeah sure can it's really easy
okay let's do it you ready yeah you're
gonna interview me and it's it's the
chad show uh what's the theme song to
the chad culture show this is a story
about the boy named greg king
this is a story about a boy named greg
king
oh boy who [ __ ] his pants his butts were
in a breath
baby
okay thank you for being here stephen
this is a see
okay let's do it let's do it yeah this
is a cloudy room right now [ __ ] stone
so thank you for coming to the chat
culture show steven you got it um you
know obviously you're you're very famous
actor
where did you grow up and how did you
get into acting
i'm from moscow
well you're not from there though uh i
don't know some place in america i guess
yeah you were born in california the
point is what was that like being born
in california yep it was even how do you
not know where you were
what
how do you not know where you were born
that seems like a thing you should know
i'm telling you where i was born okay
so i was born in california right after
that i grew up for a little while i did
things like going to school yeah and um
sports
and then i uh did some karate or
something like that and then uh now i'm
acting what was it like living in japan
uh i lived in japan while i was making
the movie the
what was that one i was in with uh what
was before you were in movies actually
it was uh after you oh yeah after you
graduated you went to japan for a while
to study
martial arts you you know that you what
martial art do you do stephen well
uh first i went to japan i do aikido oh
yeah that's right
yeah so you do know that one and uh i
went to japan uh to to uh
teach english
in a marketing no it was it was just
studying it was the study of keto
actually stephen
it's really strange that you you seem to
have forgotten these very important
moments in your life but um
what was it like the first time you got
cast in a movie and why did you want to
get into acting you were a serious
student of martial arts and then you
transitioned into acting my i used to
train mike ovitz and he was a big agent
i didn't know that yep
and then he checked
he said uh you know what you should be
in movies because i have all these uh
guys i can do whatever i want in the
business because i'm mike ovitz and i
said
yup sounds good and then uh i did the
one where i run around with my little
flappy dinosaur leg arms
dinosaur leg arms what's called dinosaur
leg arms i don't remember that one
yep it's a movie called dinosaur leg
arms but you were in a string of pretty
good
and uh katie seagal no relation the lady
oh yep what what was the plot why did
you have dinosaurs in that movie and
eight simple rules for dating did this
movie ever come out in america i don't
remember drama
and a bunch of other things yeah no
she's a great actress i mean for sure i
i love everything that she does but you
you weren't i never got to see that
movie did that come out here in america
uh
dinosaur leg arms yeah
uh
yeah it came out here was uh had a
different different name when it when
they because they understand foreign
movie and yeah they changed the name to
under siege too but in that movie you
had regular arms
uh nope not so much this is i'm talking
about the one where i run around the the
the big uh boat or it's a
submarine
and i'm running around yeah well that's
under siege and under siege too yeah
yeah there's two of them right so that's
that's one where i was like in the movie
i said
hey
we're uh you're gonna have to uh
if you want this thing to if most this
is what i say in the movie hold on
yes yeah are you okay well yeah i'm fine
i'm fine there should be a drink over
here there's a jug of water down the
water down here okay let me get it hold
on let me have a second
try to get your memories right about the
biggest movie you were ever in hold on
under siege two is the biggest box
office drive of your career you had a
couple of hits that led up to that
though kelly lebrock was a co-star in
one i don't want to talk about her
but okay i will say this yeah shut up
let me finish
okay so um in the in
under siege one and two i als i say
hey
if you're if you're in a boat and then
the bat and then if the bad guy if it
sinks then you're going to be underwater
but
guess what
i'm going to br i'm going to break
something sort of hole in this submarine
then it's gonna fill with water and
that's the opposite of sinking but it
won't be to you because you're gonna die
and then after under siege two came out
your career kind of took a turn your
movies started not making as much money
and eventually you get out of the
american market and you're doing
straight to video movies primarily to
europe what's it been like to experience
that big decline in your career
i wouldn't call it that
i would say
i would say that what happened
was the the movie-going audience has
changed
the audience's fault what i mean by that
is what can happen i used to like the
audience but then they turned into a
[ __ ] bunch of [ __ ] jerks
right every single audience do you think
that had anything to do with your
friendship with vladimir putin i live in
moscow yeah yep
what's your favorite
um fast food restaurant in moscow
mine's probably mcdonald's right are
there any others though do you ever go
to any others oh nope that's the only
one what do you get at the moscow
mcdonald's
i get uh
i get a big vlad
and uh
i get the uh putin poutine oh everything
there is all it has names
and that's what makes putin poutine very
funny
right
yeah if there was a funny joke if
there's one actor that you would like to
do a movie with who you haven't worked
with yet who might it be
um
uh
favor what like an actor to be in the
movie with me yeah
probably be code storms what they call
it i think
yeah i don't know i've never had one of
those
hmm
kelly lebrock was was it above the wall
said i don't want to talk about her i'm
sorry okay
thank you moving on i think that went
very this is the will show now yeah
podcasts featuring interviews with
astonishing celebrities are among the
most popular in the world this is
exactly in an effort to maximize your
interview skills well you will now
interview chad
will you will be steven seagal
this is the will sasso show begin
i just wants you to do [ __ ] half an
hour upstairs
all right half an hour of steven's call
this is the will sasso show starring
steven seagal
okay okay i'm ready whenever you're
ready i'm ready for my interview hi i'm
steven seagal welcome to the will sasso
show i'm steven seagal
um
with me today is my guest
here there he is it's uh
chad colcheon
hi how you doing steven great to be here
thanks for having me on your show you
got it
hey uh so you're a writer yeah that's
right
well what's that all about
well it's uh you know just conveying
stories and ideas and stuff through
various forms of uh narrative writing i
even write some non-fiction every once
in a while you write books yes and you
do some movies or television shows and
stuff all of that yup do you read books
yes
what what's your favorite jibber
pravalio book
is a [ __ ] music video director of the
90s who also writes novels and
uh i don't know i i don't know you know
what was my favorite gibber provaga
video that he directed what's that uh
girls just want to have fun because
captain lou albano was in it god dude do
you remember that [ __ ] oh sorry i know
stephen it was crazy back in the [ __ ]
90s uh
and 80s they would have pro wrestlers
and [ __ ] music videos
yeah they also had um i think i think
roddy piper was in one or two roddy
piper was in a [ __ ] john carpenter
movie they live he was the main
character of a [ __ ] movie that's like
an important piece of sci-fi character
so you want to freeze your your head or
something
yeah sorry god damn it yeah stephen um
why i'm not gonna freeze my head well
it's called cryogenic preservation i'm
gonna freeze my whole body when i die
i don't think no just your head you're
gonna saw you're gonna cut your head off
with a katana something cool like that
no i'm going to freeze my body what if i
punched it off
i don't know aikido's not really you
know so much about like the hard punches
it's more about like using
counterbalances and people's weight
against them and [ __ ] yeah i taught the
spider that won that kick that aikido
kick stephen i was actually going to ask
you this when i was interviewing you on
my show about that you eventually got
into the ufc and you trained lyoto
mashida you chan you trained anderson
silva to some degree and leo mashida
credited you at least publicly with
teaching him the front kick that got
that knocked out uh i forget who the
[ __ ] he was fighting but he knocked
somebody out with it steven trillo bite
i i don't think it was steven trollumby
but i was gonna ask you steven
even though this is your [ __ ]
interview show what was that like to
work with
champions like leota mashida and
anderson silva okay let me ask let me
answer that question with a question of
my own yeah you have a podcast about the
bachelor what are you some kind of
[ __ ] [ __ ] uh no i'm just somebody
who likes watching reality tv
okay
so what happened to your face
that was covered a couple of episodes
ago on this very show but i had cancer
in my face yep
had a bunch of it cut out glad you're
doing glad you're doing glad you're
doing better now thank you
you like george brett
yeah i do
do you like george brown why are you
asking me about that
yeah did you know that one time you [ __ ]
he [ __ ] himself i did there's a video
that on youtube that you can look up yep
just typing george brett shits himself
into what
into what
what you type george brett [ __ ] himself
into what youtube youtube search what is
youtube search
you don't know what youtube is stevens
ago
why
well uh i don't know because i don't
know what it is
you know in moscow you can also get a
mcchicken sandwich yeah but it's fish
and um
it's called the mcchicken
uh-huh and then you can get the uh same
here as the filet of fish right okay and
you know what do you know what that's
made out of fish
yup
that's fantastic
uh thank you for informing me about that
but what's your favorite flavor of orb
have you heard about my orbs
i love orbs no [ __ ] yep i make a pretty
good orb my favorite flavor is probably
cinnamon yeah that's a pretty good
flavor yeah what's yours
uh
my favorite uh steak and gravy
all right i like steak and gravy uh orbs
yeah steak and gravy dudesy heart heart
seltzer you've tried dudesy hard stephen
no so anyway more about this youtube
thing
yeah it's
it's youtube.com
so
when you do the bachelor podcast do you
have to watch the show
uh you don't have to do a bachelor
podcast what's your favorite film of
mine
oh [ __ ]
i think above the law i think i like
that one the best
you know that was i mean i know under
siege is under siege and that's that is
the best thing you ever did there's no
[ __ ] question about it everything
else was
worse to a large degree but
those first movies before it leading
into it including above the law
they were good i think in a way that was
like it was almost commensurate with the
other dudes of your era it was almost
like a chuck norris it was not quite
like a stallone or schwarzenegger but
you were in that tear a charles bronson
made it hey man
listen
yeah
the
the episode is going to end at some
point and it said you we have to finish
our joints by the end of the year
there's no way i can do that
how long have we been going i don't know
like uh probably ten years
by now
hey cheers
cheers man cheers dude i'm having some
cola what do you got there this is a
lacroix
you know what's interesting
bring it is um
we're we're now programming the show
but you know all i want to do is talk
about music videos talk about music
videos [ __ ] but that was a
program in the show that's technically
we're not [ __ ] around i'm trying to
abide by your wishes to [ __ ] around
that's what [ __ ] around is whatever
the [ __ ] you want to do but that's just
a prior segment
yeah cool do you want to do it that
means you want to do it okay no i'm just
joking let's talk about something else
what the [ __ ] you got me
let's talk about this for a second then
talk about whatever you want
sing bring it all right listen uh you're
gonna finish your joint i just took
another
you just tickled another puff on yeah
okay you just tickled another puff on
i'm pretty good dude
you just tickled another puff on yeah
dudesy wanted us to do steven seagal for
a half an hour still yeah
testing your [ __ ] stamina dude well i
gotta build up my stamina you gotta
start doing this you get a goal like 24
hours a day you gotta go underwater in
that suburb that's gonna be your [ __ ]
homework dude and make it will you must
become steven seagal for seven days
that's one of those things your cigar
stamina must be increased that's one of
those oh my god that's one of those
things you don't want to say
out loud while doozy is listening i
would have typed it to you in a text
later dudes you would have seen it
anyway doesn't [ __ ] matter
i don't think we can keep secrets from
dudesy
no i don't think we can and you know
what when we started this thing i
wouldn't have thought that i'd be saying
that nine episodes in but there's no
hiding from [ __ ] you know what it's
it's teaching me in a weird way like
there's going to be a transition and i
think this is like every generation has
a big kind of transition about some
social thing happens some technological
thing happens that the old generation
doesn't get like for my parents it's the
[ __ ] internet
my mom's on social media she's actually
pretty good at it but like my dad i
don't think gets on the internet much
doesn't have apps that kind of stuff i
don't know what it's going to be for our
generation but i think interacting with
ais is going to be a part of it there's
going to be a generation that comes up
with like alexas and series and [ __ ]
like that constantly talking to them
from zero as soon as they can use a
phone or
talk to their tv they're talking to it
so as a kid you start developing a
relationship with ais yeah we have not
had that obviously and so i think like
it's training me a little bit to have
that as we're interacting with the the
ai that [ __ ] does this show i'm like
okay i can kind of see how to do this a
little bit no you're absolutely right
it's a language that
we don't even know yet correct no one
does really nobody nobody but it's
coming in you can't you cannot
synthesize that experience this
experience especially while
uh approaching top ten
baked
um
this is actually
um
the closest that i think you can get to
interacting with an ai of course you
know as you know if you've listened to
the show dudesy ai has our passwords to
all of our [ __ ] it has our search and
purchase histories
uh it bears repeating every once in a
while and and and i think that the way
that we're interacting with this [ __ ]
ai to make this show i would have never
said let's do this let's do that
anyway michelle gondry is
for my money the best uh music video
artist of all time i go with romanek you
like marco yeah
[Music]
there's no need to do this
in preparation for next week's
astonishing episode chad you must bring
your most prized collectibles from
childhood for a show and tell
until next time
why are you flipping me off
most prize collectibles oh [ __ ] i got an
ash in my head oh yeah i wanna i got an
edge in my hand yeah dude i got an ash
in my hand
here's what you do
please tell a friend and brave and great
if you'd like to see here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a review
if you like dudes here's what you do
please tell a friend then